Eric.
Do you hear me?
Yeah, yeah, we got you.
Alright,
I'm gonna go on mute for a bit because
it's pretty loud for me.
Yeah, that's fine. Wait,
the first like 10, 15 minutes anyway,
we're just going to roll through like we
said, and then, you know, when she starts,
when we hand it over to her,
that's when really you'll probably need
to.
Alright, sounds good.
Even so, alright.
Hello.
Hey.
How are you?
I'm good, how are you?
Doing well.
So we got Brian on here and get Jared.
So before we get into it,
I'll just kind of frame what's happened
the last, you know, four or five days.
So we've, I know,
I don't know if you've logged in and
checked,
but essentially we've made the big
reconciliations even
Okay.
last night into this morning.
and fix some really compounding errors,
I think,
that were foundational to some of the
things we talked about.
And I want to go through that with you
real quick.
I'm going to share my screen and just
kind of drive through some of the things
in case...
That way you know where they are, right?
And just since I don't know when you
logged in,
I want to make sure we're all starting
from the same page. And then up front,
one of the things we'll do as well after
this, I've got a package of documents,
basically updated SOW.
that's going to reflect where we are now.
And then I added a full engagement
timeline for the work done.
That includes, you know,
emails with the vendors and there's also
a third document that's a feedback ledger.
That's just essentially showing.
everything that we talked about, the team,
right,
and what has been raised and what has
been delivered.
It's just meant to be a clean record.
So that way you have everything to review,
share, ask us questions on,
that kind of thing. I did not
included ahead of time,
just because I wanted to walk through all
this first and then let you see it after
we've done that. Is that okay?
Yeah, sure.
Yeah,
we can walk through it and then I can
maybe kind of once maybe some of it you
walk through, I can kind of
ask some questions or kind of tell you
where I'm at with how I think this,
you know,
looking at using this where we are.
OK, so.
But I still have, like,
I still have a few, I mean,
a few concerns about the workflow and
kind of how this is set up to work.
And then I know we talked specifically
kind of about these 100% matched loads
not matching without photos.
And I still feel like that,
Mhm.
like that's happening.
Yes, and I will talk to that.
So that was one of the main fixes that we
But okay, yeah, we go through.
made,
but I will go through all of that because
if you logged in at like 530 or 6 or even
7, you would have seen some discrepancies.
obviously,
and so I realized that last night, later.
So that's why we had a reconciliation
session probably about midnight.
And you'll see that reflected in the
timeline. But I'll just go through here.
NOC.
Because I'm on now. I mean,
but I'll let you walk through it,
but I'm on now and I'm just seeing
several.
that are still that way.
But maybe you share your screen and I'll
kind of see.
Okay.
So, since this is essentially...
Because PCS has been the gating factor,
that has created another element of
difficulty because what we are trying to
do in parallel of waiting on them, right,
which is the real return on investment
kind of pathway,
we wanted to have a way for you guys.
to use it, well,
because of the way JotForm brings in
pictures, right,
we had to aggregate all of the flows.
So this is the first time the system is
seeing it, right?
So it is doing its job in the sense of
ingesting, right?
And it's trying to match,
but the feedback loops are a continuous
improvement.
right?
So every feedback that you guys give it,
we'll continue to make it better.
And I will kind of show you what that
looks like. But off the bat, you know,
one of the things we fixed right away is
now you see more realistic numbers, right?
The
dating has basically said, you know,
everything that was historically that you
guys have already, you know, sent to PCS,
that's good. It lives in archive, right?
So your objective numbers are a little
bit more manageable, like you would see.
And you
we'll always be able to see like kind of
how your data flows are, right? So PropX,
logistics,
the JotForm pipeline goes every 30
minutes, and the auto mapper.
So you get to see the status right here
when you log in.
So you'll know right up front if anything
is wrong.
Um...
And so, we'll start with the Desk.
We added the color scheme that you guys
had wanted, and we are gated, obviously,
by PCS, but once they, you know, get...
The OAuth to us, these will be unlocked,
so it will start to follow kind of how
you guys.
Tag looks so.
I know one of the things was, you can...
roll through this with your keyboard now,
that was one of the things that I think
Scout had asked for.
But as far as the 100% match, so it was a,
are you referring to like how it says be
all here?
And here, like it's not a match.
No,
I'm just referring to the loads that
don't have an image there,
but they're saying they're 100% matched.
So there are 100% matched because what
happened, the historical data, it has,
it found, you know,
either an alias for a well or something
of that matter.
So it's matching based on data that it's
pulling from multiple data points, right?
Like just fields that it.
That it can try to map on right now,
that doesn't mean that it'll go forward
anywhere without a photo, so...
That means that the BOL, you know,
reconciliation pipeline,
all those learning things we put in place.
The system is going to continue to try to
map those retroactively, right?
So like since we've been here,
it started at 1427 and we're at 1436.
So it is actively going through the
process and attaching those to loads.
So if you don't see some right now.
It's going through the entire corpus of
the Jotform photos as they get put in now,
right? And everything that was, you know,
backloaded this month, right?
Or this year, essentially.
So it is going through deterministic rule
checks and things of that nature to try
to match. But.
just for the purpose of, you know,
showing the dispatch Desk flow.
We corrected the...
You know,
you said that the BOL was off like the
ticket number, so we made sure to...
Correct that,
and now you see the truck number right
underneath it.
You've got a couple of places that you
can view and look.
Right, all here. You can also click here,
do the same thing. If there's an issue,
you can flag it and it puts it.
over to the queue or the issue.
So on that one specifically,
I'm curious where this BOL came from
because and that's what might get can.
Right here on the ticket, B581018,
because we had talked and I remember you
saying the BOL and the ticket number are
often...
you know, a metric of match. Yes.
The same,
but where you have you have a BOL number
86906478?
Yes, so this was a PropEx, not PropEx,
but the other one, logistics.
So because we normalized the data,
you guys are used to seeing it in
individual streams, right?
So one of the things I wanted to talk
about today was how to attack that, right?
Because it is matching based on the
criteria that you and your team works
with.
but the system has all of these different
fields that it normalizes with, right?
So it is pulling this from.
Logistics,
because they have this is a metric on
their end.
And it has cross-referenced that.
And so it's basically just a labeling
quirk.
So it's really one of those things where
you tell us exactly like.
all you want to see is B51018 because
this is a back end like when it comes
over from logistics, if that makes sense.
Okay.
And I can show you that in logistics,
if you, if you want me to.
I mean, that's not necessary.
Yeah, it's just a, it's like I said,
it's a data thing.
So it's really arbitrary.
You can tell us exactly what you want
surfaced if you want it to say, you know,
I can append it to say, you know,
logistics.
or whatever, it just,
it came over because it is a part of the
auto mapping.
It's one of the tiers that help it make
sure that it's going to grab.
the correct BLO number.
And so we.
I know we said weight back to pounds.
That is one of the gating,
that's an easy change.
We wanted to focus on the things that.
we could show you that make it feel more
operational. I know we added notes.
You can copy all events.
tried to make it more like what you're
used to. We added the dates.
So if you come here and you want to look
at...
That week.
You can click on the well and it surfaces
the ones.
that you've done for that time period.
And of course, as you know,
you can add different wells.
We also added an easy search here,
so you can search for a load at any time.
There's a little claim button here,
so that way if you're the user, Jessica,
and you want to claim a load,
so that way everyone knows you're the one
working on it, you can do that there.
And then here for the queue,
so this one says pending.
Right, so as you can see it,
the rules were able to pull.
this BOL number,
so it's pulling that right there.
The deterministic rules are working.
And so like, let's just make sure 0454.
That one looks like it's fine.
So this would be one that, you know,
it doesn't have a match to a load yet,
right? So...
This is one that...
You would match, you know.
or the girls would match down the road.
And one of the things I want to flip to
real quick is this is where we're going
with it, right?
We're taking a break here to show you
operational because we've ran into,
you know, the issues with,
we want to make sure that you guys know
we are shipping.
You know.
Deliver like the system is working, right?
It's just PCS is the one major gating
obstacle at the moment.
And when you say that PCS is the obstacle
because we cannot import in,
is that what you're referring to?
Yes, there's no bidirectional,
there's no bidirectional,
Like, we can't actually...
and you can't push, right?
So one of the things that...
We decided to do was to make a natural
way for you guys to take your workflow.
and transition a little easier into the
push to PCS.
So that is why there was the intentional
addition of the validation.
This eventually goes away, right?
This won't stay forever.
It's just it is because we took this.
Project, and we both, you know,
we were aligned on the fact that we
wanted to make sure.
everything was going to be correct.
We added a lot of reconciliation,
a lot of double checking tiers into this
so that way we could, one,
ensure that the learning was going to
happen at a very high rate, and two,
that when you push the PCS when it was
ungated,
you were going to get a very, you know,
high confidence rate that it was going to
push correctly, right?
We wanted to ship with confidence and not.
mess anything up for this particular
piece of the process since it was so
important.
But what made it difficult was we had to
work around that PCS pushing because it
made us have to facilitate a workflow
that, you know, gives you a...
some kind of tangible value to show you,
you know, hey, we can work in this.
And when it's ready to push,
we'll feel comfortable, right? So it was..
.
A targeted decision to kind of...
Hope you guys feel more comfortable,
comfortable about the workflow,
but we needed this validation and and
queue pieces to help train the system,
right, because...
That's the most important piece is really
the learning,
and that's where you get the highest
return.
And one of the things we talked about,
I think, Jessica,
in our validation calls was the
validation queue didn't feel exactly
right, correct?
So this is the fix to that.
This is what we will implement if we,
you know,
When we get everything signed,
everything agreed on,
this piece right here kind of melds the
two, so it's not.
A different view,
and I think this might make more sense.
Would you agree or disagree?
Because what this will do is meld the BOL.
queue basically with the validation in
one page. So you get to see.
what's matching, how it's matching,
and the ticket, you know, side to side.
Yeah, possibly,
possibly that might make a little more
sense. Honestly, looking at this,
we're not, we can't utilize this.
I guess that's been the concern is we
keep looking at this with like a two day,
you know,
in two days we're going to go live with
this, in two days we're going to go live.
And I'm looking at it like currently,
you know, I mean, we can't use
what I'm looking at, even still,
for several reasons.
We could get in and do some of the things,
like I can see the load,
I can see what this is doing,
but for us to actually utilize this
before it's pushing is not,
it's just not a reality.
There's no way for me.
Two.
And our terminology is different,
but essentially validate the loads.
and get those pushed out to the girls.
It looks like maybe they're going to be
waiting on photos.
They're going to have to search those.
So, were they not weighed?
It's just not functional.
It.
And so I guess my concern is...
Well, I guess I'm confused because like,
you know, this one,
would this not be an example of a
functional usable?
Hello.
I just want to understand. Like this one,
it has pulled in.
Sure. This one, this one is, yes,
this one is. But my concern is,
Okay.
so when I was in this morning,
kind of looking, I did my dates,
because this one's from April 4th.
So if you actually put in like the 13th
to the 15th,
which would be more like what we're
working on, I mean,
so many of those photos still aren't
attached to those.
Well, and like I mentioned,
one of those reasons is because it is
retroactively pulling in JotForm, right,
every 30 minutes.
That, yeah.
And so one of the things that I mentioned
in the document is yes,
maybe there should have been a little bit
more communication,
but because it's kind of esoteric in how
all of that works on the back end.
it is actively doing the matching behind
the scenes.
And that is why I was saying what I did
this weekend about not wanting to rush
the operational piece because the
pipeline has to catch up, right?
We're trying to get you guys the highest
match rate we can. And at this moment,
since we wanted to have, you know,
the meeting and we had the questions
about, you know, where everything stands,
I went ahead and connected it only at the
63, 66% level, right?
So at this moment in time, yes, there are.
If this is going to take more time,
you know, say you're like,
you need two more.
I just need to know that.
I need to know like that this isn't ready
because it's hasn't had enough time to do
its job on the backside.
And then we can evaluate, you know,
I'm going to have to take that back to my,
it can be like,
we're a month out from this thing,
you know, really, for two weeks or a week,
it's just only at 67%.
I just can't have the girls in there.
right now, two and three days out,
you know,
going in and looking at this and not
having all that information,
Yeah.
because then they're having to still do,
I mean, basically what we're doing.
Yeah, it.
Yes, yes, and I understand that.
And I guess, you know,
should have made it more clear.
I brought you guys in last week just so
like we could get some direction on if we
were going the right direction, right?
But yes, absolutely,
it does need more time to match. And that,
OK.
and that is,
so this is how the feedback work loops,
right? And, and.
And this is with real driver information,
right? So today you're at 66.2%, right?
Within 2 weeks, that jumps to 82.
So what that means is, you know, 82%,
right, as long as the...
the time frames line up, you know,
that'll be 82% match.
Okay.
Okay, well, I mean,
a lot of it looks good.
We could go into more.
I don't know if it's necessary as far as
kind of how this is mapped out,
because if the validation goes away,
What I?
that kind of, that changes our process,
which is okay.
Well, the validation doesn't go away.
I don't want you to think it goes away,
right? It just, it looks,
it looks less confusing, right?
Night.
This is still validation, right?
it just,
you get an easier way to match things and
validate. Like it feels more natural,
right?
Like right now you're having to go
between both spots,
or if you are on the validation,
it's like, well,
this doesn't help you much, right?
Yeah, for sure. I mean, this does not.
So, yes, so,
but this kind of situation would,
if you were able to come to one spot,
look at it.
See, like here,
it tells you why it didn't match.
You know, it didn't find anything.
You can fix it. You get to decide.
You can confirm.
And then you can even go into one that
was a tier 3,
because what we've done is if it doesn't
have an alias, right, or it doesn't have,
like if it doesn't know,
where to put it.
The default behavior is to always go to a
tier 2 or tier 3 so that way you can give
it input so it can learn, right?
We have intentionally done that,
so that way...
You guys are able to either, you know,
if it's new, added, if it's a new driver,
take care of it. You know,
if it sees that a driver submits,
you know, a ticket that are two places,
right? There's a rule in there that...
It makes you guys check on that first.
And if we need to dial back how, you know,
picky it is, we can do that too.
I can send you a list of the rules that
are in place now. And you can tell me,
you know,
this needs to be dialed back or this
doesn't. But we
It was my understanding we wanted to be
very intentional about.
Making sure it knew exactly how to map,
and since it is so precise,
Well, and...
it does it does come off overwhelming, so.
..
Yeah,
I think just the amount of time it's
taken. I mean, obviously,
the more precise the better, but I mean,
this is where we kind of get into the
business side of things. And I mean,
Mike can't wait six months and have,
you know,
Yeah.
and this is just the import part. I mean,
and honestly, it's not worth
Well, it's been 40 days waiting on PCS,
I'll be honest,
and we started on February.
Sure, but he spent 7000, you know,
he's spending money waiting,
and it's not your fault necessarily,
and he understands that, but he's like,
Mm.
I also cannot do this financially.
Yeah, no.
And that's why we wanted to stop at this
point, right?
Send you these documents so you can see
exactly what you've gotten based off of,
you know, the conversations we've had.
And then you can tell us, you know,
how you want to proceed.
Okay, yeah, that works.
So I'll just go ahead and share those
documents with you and then
I.
Now we can go from there.
Okay, sounds good.
Brian, anything?
No,
that seems pretty much kind of where what
I was thinking as well.
I'm gonna throw them in the chat here,
and you can...
Very open from there.
Oh.
I.
And I'll email you copies as well,
but this way you can, everybody can.
Rabbit, so this is a statement work.
That I'm adding first.
Actually, I can add it in chat,
just let me email it to you.
Yes.
S.
I.
All right,
so this will be a PDF copy of the
engagement timeline on SOW,
and then there is a full package that
combines everything with a,
that's essentially just a ledger.
a ledger view of everything that has been
covered. I will just give you a brief.
Overview.
So I sent these separate,
but you have the statement of work that's
separate.
And then there's an engagement timeline.
And then the team feedback ledger,
like we talked about. So,
and this document just puts it all
together in one form.
Okay, perfect.
And it tells you exactly what, you know,
has been delivered at this point.
Obviously, the matching, all of that,
the surface, what's cross-cutting,
the infrastructure,
and it just talks to the...
Capabilities.
what, you know, out of scope, in scope,
exactly what the fees, you know,
are getting you.
It answers in depth more your ownership,
you know, that question to your email,
what's what, you know, who owns what,
and then timeline and milestones.
Mhm.
starting from, you know,
we only started building in February.
And so this kind of details exactly,
you know, the entire pathway to now.
And then, yep,
and then the rest of it just kind of goes
Okay.
into even more detail.
So that way you guys can see the hour
accounting and kind of the active bill
flow.
So, if you have any questions,
let us know.
Okay.
Okay,
so I will forward this on as far as these
documents and kind of go over them with.
Mhm.
Mike, and I mean,
he can he can look at the documents,
but what I'll probably do is have him
just kind of sit down,
him and Jeri sit down and get into the
system and kind of show them where we are.
But that, you know,
we're kind of in a waiting phase at this
point until the system has had time to
Learn,
learn what it needs to learn to do the
mapping.
Yeah, because yeah, it's three different,
you know,
it's coming from three different streams,
so we're trying to aggregate everything
and then give deterministic rules, so it,
yeah,
it's just trying to catch up at this
point.
And so,
and I will let you know kind of what...
what he wants to do based on kind of what,
you know, the documents say.
And if he wants to move forward,
I guess we will,
you will just let me know when we're at a
point where maybe this will be something
we can utilize.
Well, as soon as, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just I think right now what we're going
to wait on you guys, see what you say,
and then, you know, we're not going to.
Do any building or any updating until we
hear back,
and there's some agreement on next steps,
but yes.
It's gonna it's gonna still process those
those image files though, correct?
Yeah, it will.
Mhm.
Yes, it'll still process.
I'm just saying nothing that new.
Yeah,
like I don't want to stop that process.
Yeah.
Yeah, we just, well,
and even if I think looking at this,
because I'm a little,
and I think maybe hopefully when I read
through the documents,
it'll kind of map this out because we're
kind of in this, you know,
Mark wanted the import to happen and that
sounded easy.
Like that was a pretty quick thing that
we could do. And then if that worked out,
And he's just extremely leery because
we've done this once. And it wasn't good.
It didn't end up being good.
It was an astronomical amount that he
spent.
I think he went into that a little bit
with you guys.
And then we didn't have anything at the
end of the day. So he wants us to work,
but he also wants to be wise in what he's
Getting himself into, but I...
Well, I would say the import has happened,
like the import from PGS is here,
like the data is all here,
it's all imported, the 30, 40,000 loads,
since you know that is here,
it is ingesting and it is working, right?
It's just we...
You can see that it's just not a product
we can use, which is...
The this is actually the.
Where we were before.
This is actually the hard part, Jessica.
Like,
so this here is going to format all the
data, right? The import to PCS.
It is.
Push a button. Yeah.
Yeah,
because we've already made the railway,
Yeah, it's gonna be the, you know, it.
right? It's already there.
We are literally just waiting on them to
And that's kind of what...
give us those credentials.
And that's kind of what we talked about
yesterday when we were kind of just
looking at this and going over it.
That was my, what I kind of said is like,
I think that this is probably, you know,
one of the parts that's taken the longest,
like I said,
but also just it's his decision and
looking at where he's come from.
He's like, I hear you. Like I hear
No, we, yeah, we get it.
you know, that this takes time.
But with that being said,
we did this and that was kind of the same
conversation. I mean,
he would show us stuff too,
and it was all there,
but it was nothing we could ever use.
And I'm not saying that's what's
happening.
He just needs to know that he's not going
to wind up back in the same situation
that we've been in previously.
And then looking at this, Jace,
from what you and I have talked about
Oh yeah.
Quite a few times.
So we're waiting on this to do kind of
100%,
but I feel like we're going kind of
toggling back and forth on trying to push
something out that we can use in this gap.
And I don't know.
I don't know if we that's a good idea.
If it was up to me,
I wouldn't want to do that.
I would want to wait, right? And,
you know,
I think you and I have been aligned on
that most of the time. Let's, you know,
it's an internal development process to
make sure we get it right. And I,
you know, I...
Take that on me.
We were trying to get you guys something
you could use because we knew about the
urgency, right? But obviously...
Yeah,
I think that's making it more confusing.
Yes, yes.
And so that's why when you sent that
email, I told Brian, I was like,
let's just stop.
Let's go ahead and define everything. And,
you know, leave it in there for, you know,
let's make sure that they're comfortable
before we continue. Right.
And so that's where this came from.
Did you get the email?
Um...
Yeah.
Yes, I did. It came through.
So I'll just go over that with the mic
Okay.
and kind of, you know,
tell them we're looking at a couple weeks
to a month maybe on this thing, maybe.
being ready to push.
And then I would think if in a month PCS
hasn't like granted that access,
they're probably not going to.
Yeah, and you can see.
I don't know what the hold up there is.
Yeah,
and you can see we have the timeline
mapped out.
It's been 40 days since we engaged them
Mhm.
initially.
And that's literally all we're waiting on.
And unfortunately, you know,
we're beholden to their process.
And you know, that was,
we made the decision to try to get you
some shippable, you know, sooner.
And I think you're right, that did.
contribute to the confusion.
So that's why, you know,
in those documents, we also state,
you know, communication will be, you know,
definitely more paramount moving forward.
So, you know,
the amount of detail that you see there
in those documents as far as decisions
and like what's happening, you know,
will be intentional about making sure
that
stays tracked and stays to you.
Because when I go and visit with Mike and
I kind of show him this,
his big deal was the import.
Like if we can do the import,
like that's kind of this trust building
that maybe we can, you know,
do all the other things. In my mind,
the import is challenging. What we have,
what you guys have
you know,
started on is great because we probably
would have had to do this regardless if
we were going to kind of build our own
system.
If we get to a point where I can look at
this and be like, yeah, I see this,
this would work if it was really just
Yeah.
like pushing it through,
he would maybe consider
like bypassing, you know, the whole PCS,
moving on to build something.
Yeah, well, that was the whole thing.
Yeah, and that was the whole thing, right?
Like, you have, we, like,
just in order to import it into PCS,
you had to have this aggregated space to
put everything together, right?
And so that was kind of the problem
underneath the problem that was really
Mhm.
the thing.
that needs to be addressed, right?
Not the import itself, but you know,
this aggregation of your data to a point
where...
you guys can import it into PCS, right?
And I think that is what is service.
Right. So I will take him.
No matter what,
so here's the thing though, is that like,
oh, sorry, go ahead. Oh, no,
what I was saying is, no matter what,
Go ahead, you're good.
you're going to have some of these,
you know,
transactions that are going to need an
image or the image is incorrect,
that there's going to have to be a manual
kind of human intervention.
Absolutely, yeah.
That's what this kind of,
this part does that.
Right.
And so while you're training it and doing
those corrections, right,
it's the same interface for that.
It's just that it's going to continually
improve at it.
And so, you know, like right now,
you're kind of looking at it and you're
Yeah.
saying, okay, you know what,
this is right, this is wrong. You know,
we can tweak that out.
But as it gets better, right,
then it's just going to give you the data
set that's, okay, here's a job.
These ones are all going.
Here's the 10 of them that you're going
to have to review.
And then you can go through that,
quickly update them.
And then it's learning from that.
But I mean,
you're only going to have a few that the
drivers are just going to do wrong.
Yeah, yeah,
the OCR is gonna be messy sometimes, so...
Trey.
But I mean, hopefully at some point, well,
and hopefully at some point, right,
we could even have it where as soon as
the driver puts it in,
it's processing it and, you know,
and sends them an email back or something
that says, hey,
You know what?
This is in the correct picture.
Okay.
This is updated.
Yeah, and that's all doable, right? But,
you know, in order to get there, you know,
Mhm.
Jeff, you're absolutely right.
We have to be comfortable on this piece.
And so, you know,
I think it's an appropriate time to pause
and make sure we get all that hashed out.
So.
Yep, yep, I...
So do you, a question is,
does somebody need to be,
because I think that's some of the
confusion too.
Okay.
I don't understand the validation tab on.
I understand kind of how we our process
and I can see where you've taken what we
do and made this.
I got I follow what's going on,
but when I look at the validation it or
even the dispatch desk,
either or they're a little confusing to
me because in my mind,
nothing would go to dispatch desk until
Yeah.
Yes, yeah, yeah. So that was,
that's one of those confusion pieces of
It had been validated.
Up.
us trying to give you a surface to work
on, right, while we're waiting.
Okay.
And I think it's more of a vocabulary
thing and that's on us, obviously.
So that's why.
But for this to work...
And we can,
we can rename some of those things as
Yeah.
well, just to make sure that it's,
you know, it makes sense to y'all.
It doesn't confuse.
Wells.
And I don't mind the, you know,
what we're calling it, but like I said,
in my mind,
we would have this tab that's validation.
And we would go in and validate whether
we're trusting the system.
And if it's more than 100%,
we're just pushing it through.
But nothing would actually be in the
dispatch Desk.
So...
until it was validated.
Okay.
Gotcha. So more of a change,
this view that's in dispatch Desk,
kind of meld the BOL and validation to
give you a drawer view like this,
but that's in more of a pre-valid,
like a pre-load.
Section.
Well, and, and, and really, you know,
right now we should be looking at every
Kind of.
single one of them, right?
And clicking a validate, validate,
Well, well, that's how the system,
and that's how the system does it, Bryan,
validate, right?
Yes.
like this right here.
It's telling you that you need to
validate all of these that have come in,
right, for this time, right?
Okay, so I have a question right here.
So if we do that though,
This is a time period.
Yeah.
because I look at this,
that's kind of what I think too.
Like I'm going to come to this validation
and I need to validate all these,
but I need to for a little while,
open these and look at them.
And so I would come here,
but I don't see a picture.
Well, and that's what this was,
that's what this next stage was, right?
Is I felt that friction that you're
mentioning right here and we were going
Okay.
to change it, but what happened was,
you know, this got surfaced this week.
So it was more of a,
let's focus on making what is available,
you know,
to show them it's operational,
operational.
And then that's why I made the decision
to make the slides as well,
so we could speak to exactly what you're
talking about here.
Because this is where you would go to
look and see.
What?
You know,
and if there's things on the validation
that you want to see, like, hey,
the image needs to be up front here.
I don't want to have to dive into this.
This is looking good. Move this here.
Those are all feedback loops that we can,
they're easy changes to make.
Yeah, like it's a real-time change, right?
And so, like, Brian, what she, like,
what you just said is this right here,
right? Like, here's the photo. You know,
it would be just like the desk just on
the validation page.
So on the validation page,
could you also set it up where when I go
to that validation page,
I can put in those dates in that will
specifically?
Yes, yes, it's just a simple,
that's a simple change. So, you know,
Okay.
essentially you're asking for it's more
of a instead of dispatch Desk,
this becomes a pre-validator, right?
And then...
Essentially, yeah.
Yeah, and so then that way, you know,
for sure, you know,
I think of it in terms of like when I was
talking to Scout and Stephanie,
it's a pre-build and then a built,
basically. And that's kind of, I think,
how...
Well,
then what you're doing is you're kind of,
How maybe?
as you're validating it,
you're basically assembling the package,
right? Where you're confident that, yeah.
Yeah, the low, yeah,
you're assembling the low, yes.
Yes, yeah, so that's...
Because...
From what I'm hearing from you guys,
no matter what we do,
whether we're trying to do an import or
build our own system,
if we're going to continue,
someone on our side,
regardless if this is something our team
uses this week or in five weeks or in
five months,
someone needs to go in and tell this that
these loads are
They need to, like, in my mind,
I would go to the...
the validation or right here that this
page you're on and I would hit validate,
validate.
Yes, yes, exactly.
That's what we're talking about giving
No.
you. Instead of saying dispatch Desk,
this would be the validate.
Um, okay, because that's what,
but somebody needs to do that for this to
learn better. Is that correct or no?
Yes,
at least for what we need is a subset,
and that's why I changed it to only a,
you know, 60 days,
because you guys have validated
essentially the historical, right?
Mhm.
Because those have been pushed,
you guys have dispatched those,
those are essentially quote unquote
validated, right?
Yeah.
Sure.
So that is why you only see a particular
number.
We needed a high enough volume to get a
very good match signal,
but not also be like, oh, wow,
I have to validate 30,000 loads.
You know what I mean?
But let me ask you this,
can you just weekly, if,
Yeah.
because we're building these loads,
probably not,
because I can communicating with PCS and
what we actually change.
MM.
I was going to say we could just weekly
go in and be like, okay,
we've got these built,
so now they're validated,
Well, well, when we get PCS unlocked,
we will get a bi-directional information
but not necessarily.
flow, and yes, that will be possible.
Mhm.
if we get PCS unlocked.
My fear is like waiting, you know,
Yes.
Yeah,
otherwise you're going to have to copy
how much longer do we wait on PCS? I mean,
I think that's going to be a question in
and paste it, right?
my cast. He's like,
you want me to spend 20,
000 on four months waiting on PCS?
Like what is the, you know,
when do we decide PCS isn't going to
cooperate?
Well, and then at that point, you know,
if we feel like that is going to be a
possibility, then it's a, well, you know,
what can I export?
What report can we export that shows what
you need us to translate over?
If that makes sense.
Like if it can be built in PCS to show us
Mhm.
Oh, I see. Okay, yeah.
an equivalent,
right,
then we can set that kind of thing on an
Mhm.
export. We can work around, you know,
that it's more manual, yes,
but we can set up some automations,
like if it is a biweekly thing,
especially for the validation, right?
That is doable.
We just want to make sure you guys show
us exactly what is, you know,
the mapping criteria in PCS that we can
pull.
Okay, okay.
Let me let me just meet with Mike and see
what even direction he wants to go and
then maybe you and I can touch base or
however.
I don't mind validating the loads as long
as I have something where I can go in and
kind of sort and do a day's worth at a
time. It shouldn't take me
much time if that helps this learn faster
and speed the process up. I just need.
Yes, it.
I need something a little more functional
than what I'm looking at.
Absolutely understand.
So I will touch base with him and then if
he is willing to continue,
Okay.
I will let you know and maybe we can push
something. But I'm going to put the,
I'm just going to kind of put it out
there with the team that we're looking at.
a while before we implement any of this.
And then I'm going to just try to start
validating and maybe touching base with
you once a week on, you know,
if it's helping and we can go from there.
Jace,
why don't you just build that validation
Okay.
piece in there and make the changes, like,
like right now? Yeah, I know, so...
Yeah, I mean, I already, you know, yeah,
I have it as a branch and ready to
scaffold. I have to put the, you know,
I have to wire the front end to it.
Okay.
So we'll go ahead and try to, you know,
in, yeah, in good faith, you know,
Because if I mess something up.
we will, I want to see if, you know,
we're going to be able to do this well.
So we'll go ahead and build.
You know that,
so that way when you check in,
you've got something to at least,
you know, validate off of, right?
Sure.
If, yeah, because I feel good about that.
If I can get in there and validate these
loads and you can kind of say like,
this is working or hey, you know,
if I hit a wrong button or it pushes
something somewhere,
we can kind of see that.
My fear right now is looking at this,
even if we kind of get it where I feel
like it's somewhat functional,
is like pushing it and the girls are
seeing a color and they're like,
I think that's ready to build.
I think that's where.
We might operate in this to help the
system and help you guys to keep,
you know, speed the process up,
but not have the whole team jump in yet.
Yeah, and, and I, I,
by no means thought you know I didn't
want to,
I was trying to include every piece of
the process so I could capture the
workflow the best,
so I apologize that was confusing.
Sure, yeah.
That's okay. And I think at some point,
pulling a few here and there might be a
The.
great idea just because I do have a
specific workflow.
I also think just being completely
transparent,
some of them are not excited about this
and want it to be exactly, you know,
Ming.
they want it to look exactly how things
look right now. And I personally don't.
Think.
I think that will slow us down and I
don't know if that's best.
I want it to do everything they need it
to do to do their jobs,
but I don't necessarily,
we don't like what we're doing right now.
Yes, and that was the whole point. Yes.
Yeah. Yeah, and that was the whole point.
We don't like the flow,
so I want it to change.
Oh.
You know, how do we capture that feeling?
And you and I have talked,
and we talked about this early on, right?
How to capture, you know,
Yeah.
what makes them feel the most comfortable
without, you know, sacrificing efficiency.
So,
Sure. Yeah, so just moving forward,
I think if you and I meet and it looks
Uh.
like it's a go, and I'm like, hey, yeah,
this is working for what, you know,
Yeah.
and then if we, you know,
if we get to a point where I integrate
this group of team to build loads from
this, and I'm like, wait a minute,
then we can kind of decide if, okay,
is this a real problem or is this just
something they're not quite comfortable
with yet?
Perfect. Absolutely, yes. And like I said,
you know,
Okay.
apologies on our end for that
miscommunication.
Should have just kept it, you know,
you and I working together on it.
That probably would have saved a lot of
back and forth. So.
Yeah, that's okay. Okay, well,
I'll visit with Mike and I will be in
touch in the next day or two.
Okay, sounds good.
Okay, thank you.
Sounds good? Yeah.
Yeah.